[Music]
we all love Disney movies they're as
warm and cozy as mom's apple pie but
there's a dark side to Disney just
beneath the surface wanna know the most
twisted part of tangled stick around
until the end to find out first time the
things smash that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up
now let's find out the dark side of
Disney you never thought about draining
the life from Island after Island frozen
we all love frozen who hasn't sung let
it go at the top of their lungs in the
car or shower we're all guilty of it no
one can deny the music from our favorite
frosty film is catchy what's not to love
about the characters the story and the
art behind the beautiful backgrounds and
joyful music is a dark secret no one
really thinks about let's take a look at
where this happy story took a turn for
the worst Elsa's magic is pretty epic
she spent most of her life trying to
hide it and all of her emotions after
years of repression she decides to set
herself her feelings and her powers free
we're 100% about her big girl power
liberation but what about the
consequences for everyone around her
when Elsa let it go she plunged her
kingdom into a sudden winter everyone
was going about their business on a
beautiful summer day and suddenly
everything was frozen the first thing to
die would have been the plants in the
kingdom that would include all of the
food crops Elsa's people needed to get
through the winter in one second she
created an instant famine plants
wouldn't be the only thing suffering
tons of animals would have been caught
off guard totally unprepared for this
sudden cold snap they'd be left without
food and some without adequate shelter
even people could have died as the
temperature dropped that's the dark fact
we just can't let go
monsters Inc okay so there's more than
one dark aspect of Monsters Inc for
example there's an entire Society of
monsters traumatizing children on
purpose to exploit their fear um who
wrote this movie did they know it was
supposed to be family-friendly that's
messed up let's ignore that nightmare
scenario and talk about something no one
even seems to notice a major part of the
plot revolves around a little girl
sneaking into the monster world everyone
is terrified of her which is pretty
satisfying it almost makes us feel
better about the whole child abuse thing
almost blue appears to remain in the
monster world for a whole day she even
goes to work with Mike and Sulley she's
missing from the human world for
probably 24 hours when Sulley finally
brings boo back to her room it's
completely undisturbed it looks exactly
the same as it did when she first
followed Sulley back to his world uh
where were her parents did no one notice
a toddler going missing for an entire
day we get that not everyone has the
same parenting style but no one came to
check on this baby for a whole day her
bedroom should have been filled with
cops or at least looked like it had been
searched
maybe Boo would have been better off
staying with Mike and Sulley at least
they kept track of her whereabouts
mostly Toy Story 3 Toy Story is one of
the highest grossing franchises of all
time
woody buzz and friends have made their
way into hearts all around the world
these movies not only gave us some of
our favorite characters but also some of
the catchiest toons in Disney history
one of the most popular and beloved Toy
Story films was the third installment
this movie was an exciting lead-up to
the emotional final film this beloved
movie has a really twisted scene Woody
Buzz Jessie Rex slinky and the potato
heads all find themselves trapped in an
incinerator this is usually the part in
any animated movies that our heroes find
a last-minute escape in an unbeatable
and moving scene that eventually happens
for these faithful friends it doesn't
come until after one of the darkest
moments in animated film history before
they make their courageous escape the
gang all decides to accept their fate
that's right they feel so hopeless that
they give up they all hold hands and
wait for death that level of hopeless
resolve is
pretty grown up that kind of dark
emotion isn't usually a feature in
children's movies there are some
seriously adult themes Madagascar
Madagascar is a playground for anyone
looking for dark movie moments for
example the lemurs are being eaten alive
by the fossa sure it may be
scientifically sound but this is a
family film please stop eating the very
little animals if you're willing to
accept the lemur feast there's one part
we should all probably talk about when
the Penguins discover they're headed to
Africa they decide that's just not going
to fly with them they do what any normal
crew of flightless birds would do they
overpower the human crew and seize
control of the ship normal right when
the Penguins get reunited with the main
characters Gloria the hippo asks what
happened to the human crew the Penguins
joked that they killed them and ate
their organs we killed him and ate their
livers only Gloria seems to have reacted
to that the Penguins assure her that
they are only kidding don't relax just
yet though they say the crew is actually
on a slow boat to China
that's a poker phrase that means a
journey so long it may never reach its
destination so basically the Penguins
left them tied up in a ship drifting at
sea the crew is basically dead Yanks the
Penguins are really psychotic Tarzan
Tarzan is definitely full of
inappropriate moments the story begins
with a horrifying shipwreck
if that wasn't traumatic enough for the
audience there's more horror to come
Tarzan is a sweet innocent little baby
he's trying to survive on a jungle
island after his parents survived a
horrible shipwreck naturally Disney
writers decided to spice things up
Tarzan's parents meet and untimely end
it's not uncommon for Disney movies to
include the death of a parent but this
was just brutal baby Tarzan watched his
parents be eaten alive by a leopard what
ice not even the darkest part of the
movie if you made it through the
shipwreck and the loss of his parents
you're in for another shock the main
villain of the story is a horrible guy
named Clayton don't get us wrong he is
definitely the worst but his death is
just brutal he gets himself tangled up
in vines while he fights Tarzan in an
attempt to free himself he hacks away at
the vines unfortunately he doesn't
remove the
wrapped around his neck Clayton loses
his balance and falls from the tree
hanging himself with his natural noose
the body isn't shown but the shadow of
his feet is visible
that's just ghastly Moana the wana is
one of the most refreshing Disney films
to be released the film lead is a strong
independent and super relatable who
hasn't felt pressured to be something
that just doesn't feel right
haven't you ever felt like the world
expected you to be one thing but your
heart wanted something else it's a
struggle we can all identify with couple
that with beautiful arts entrancing
music and hilarious jokes and you've
gotten instant classic Milan isn't all
uplifting soul-searching and goofy
demigods there's a really twisted detail
that everyone just laughs off shiny bad
guy Tama Toa isn't exactly a nice crab
he tries to eat our heroes and is a jerk
about Maui's stuff we don't have any
sympathy for him or anything at the end
of the movie Moana and now he flipped
the giant crab onto his back he's
totally stuck he wouldn't be able to
defend himself or eat
left in his position his fate was sealed
he would slowly starve to death
that's a gruesome end even for a bad guy
the slow lonely painful death Tama Toa
faced is one of the grimiest in animated
history no one seems to be alarmed that
he's trapped either as the credits
rolled the audience laughs at the
trapped crab it's not like he's a nice
guy but does he really deserve that the
good dinosaur the good dinosaur is
supposed to be an uplifting story about
friendship and acceptance that message
does come across but so do some really
dark and inappropriate moments the film
is about Arlo he's a small dinosaur who
is afraid of everything his siblings
pick on him for being the runt they
enjoy scaring him Arlo is determined to
make his parents proud on their family
farm
even if he's terrified in classic Disney
movie fashion little Arlo sees his
father die right before his eyes that's
not even the most inappropriate moment
we're going to talk about
Arlo finds himself befriending a little
human he calls spot the two of them are
lost and far from home not to worry
though spot has some great survival
skills before long spot secures them a
tasty meal when he finds some delicious
red berries the two feel like they've
hit the jackpot that is until they try a
few
that have been sitting around a little
too long after eating the questionable
fruit both spot and Arlo get a serious
bit of the giggles they even start to
hallucinate after their euphoric romp
the two crash pretty hard
seems like this used to be pretty
standard in animated films these days
any kind of altered state is pretty rare
in a family movie this moment stands out
as being a little intense for something
rated PG The Little Mermaid even the
title of this movie sounds wholesome and
sweet The Little Mermaid sounds like a
cute movie about a tiny mythical sea
creature sure the movie definitely makes
us smile but it has some dark moments
Ariel seems to have a serious identity
crisis what's so wrong with being a
mermaid why can't she accept yourself
the way she is why don't you look past
her obsession with humans you can focus
on a much darker detail that basically
gets passed right over when we meet
Ursula in her underwater cave she isn't
exactly alone she has her eels of course
but there are quite a few more
inhabitants of her home in a dark dingy
corner we find Ursula's collection of
lost souls these sad little green blobs
were once merfolk too they had their own
dealings with the sea witch and are now
doomed to life as a pile of goo the
expressions on their faces say it all
some are stricken with so much sadness
while others seem to have been driven
insane with grief the garden of lost
souls is one of the darkest parts of the
original story Hans Christian Andersen
wasn't afraid to go to some pretty
twisted places with his writing you turn
back into a mermaid you belong to me
Mulan when we think of dark Disney films
Mulan isn't the first title that springs
to mind usually we hear the name of this
brave warrior and think of catchy tunes
and empowerment the film manages to
balance a plot based on war with
uplifting moments really well there are
a few dark moments in the story
Mulan's father deciding to face the
hearts before when he's already disabled
is one of them with his physical
struggles he's resigning himself to a
swift death on the battlefield the film
gets even darker when Mulan and her
fellow soldiers reach Shen's village
they find it burned to the ground and
smoldering the audience is wrapped up in
the grief Shen feels for his
father but the horror of one small
detail seems to be glossed over a tiny
doll is found in the ashes the
implication is clear it wasn't just
adults that died in the village the DA
served as a depressing symbol of just
how unforgiving war is it doesn't care
if you're young old stick anything the
doll reminds us all that violence is
devastating it's a serious detail and
one that is super creepy my father
should have been here
tangled tingle is one of the cutest
Disney films of all time we can't get
enough of the beautiful colors happy
songs and fun characters I mean come on
that chameleon is adorable and Flynn's
horse has so much personality
he's a main character who can resist the
love story between Rapunzel and Eugene
it's definitely not the darkest Disney
movie out there there is one detail that
is pretty messed up and no one ever
talks about it
Rapunzel's beautiful golden hairs
Magic's not just because it's so long
and always looks freshly brushed we mean
it's literally magic she can heal the
wounded and even restore the dead those
aren't your everyday locks it takes more
than the right hair mousse to do that
what's messed up is that when Rapunzel's
hair is cut it loses its magical powers
and turns brown that's a messed up
message to send to little girls
blond hair is magical and can perform
miracles but Brown is just blah Brown is
just what you're left with when all the
magic is gone this isn't a new idea
people have assigned stereotypes to hair
colors since variations first appeared
haven't you heard that blondes always
have more fun or heard jokes about
genders Rapunzel was beautiful as a
blonde but she's just as beautiful as a
brunette too we hope you liked this look
into the sinister side of Disney we'll
catch you next time
[Music]